I guess we can't Celine Dion in the City
of Light today with our Carly's feelings
been in Paris for two weeks of concerts
and of course you can't miss out a
fashion week right and what a reception
Celine got from the French today was
really an outpouring of emotion and love
and Carly you were right there every
step of the way
hello from the streets of Paris you know
Selena and I got to talk about
absolutely everything including how
she's coping with the loss of her
husband Renee next Thursday of course
marks six months since his passing but
here in Paris Selena's learning to find
her smile again
are you ready to to hit it me I was born
ready
gracious and giving Celine stops to give
love to as many fans as she can
every day they've been swarming the
Royal Monaco hotels just hoping for a
one on one moment with their idols who
else can comfort a crying baby with her
charm she cooled oh no no what's been
the fan response and what's that meant
to you seeing all these people here for
you well first of all I have to say that
coming here after the passing of my
husband after not even six months it
could have been way easy for me to say
you know what I'm not in the mood of
dressing up and having the the purse and
seeing the fans and having a good time
and singing giving a part of your soul
you know but knowing that he loved the
industry so much he made me who I am
today
since I'm 12 years old you know have
been criticized for being an open book
for so long but it's been enough today
because they know me well her three sons
are with her and they are loving all the
Parisian fashion vibes they love to
dress do they yeah ooh me too I mean
I mean I have to buy stuff because they
dressed up and they play I mean they're
not just boys I just wanted what they're
saying no they want this hat and gears
in the back that I can anyway that's fun
for you though the Apple did not fall
very far from the trees every day Celine
has been stunning us with her couture
fashion
first of all do do we know any girls in
the world don't really like to be
jeweled or dressed up or not famous
I never met one her new chic love comes
from stylist LaRoche who has also
created looks for ariana grande and
Scindia us together as a team as a
collaboration we just having a good time
like we haven't fun in terror it's just
to have a good time and play you know
you were ingenious as much fun as a long
gown singing in an up-tempo song God
there's much fun as a rock n roll or a
ballad you don't want to make people cry
all night if you don't want to make them
go so loud you need to assist some
different emotions
Julie what are you made this amazing fan
reaction they'd only lyrics of my songs
better than I do them myself
they transport me to another level and
there's such supporters beyond music we
have a relationship for many many years
own but that's what comes out of it
Selina's completing two weeks of
sold-out shows in Paris Montreal is next
starting July 31st and for tonight's gig
she invited me along and we do we have
some great behind-the-scenes footage
that we are so excited to show you and
we'll bring all of that cute and more
tomorrow when Celine sits down backstage
for an intimate conversation